hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Caroline
this is Caroline guys she is a model and
I am always nervous when I'm around her
hi hi Hey she came on the channel before
we revamp the whole channel it's fun
having her back don't look at me for too
long I get really nervous when you look
look directly at me it's a terrifying
feeling she's naked right now pure naked
no you revealed it
you revealed it uh yeah Caroline's a
model ever question actually as a model
how did you know that you were like that
good looking where you could be a model
if you remember in high school I didn't
feel like I was that good-looking you
didn't feel like you guys thought you
were so hot in high school damn I cannot
talk to you I was too nervous I always
had the hotter older sister always yeah
hot rollers really like referred to as
Poppy's younger oh okay so I never
thought I was the hot one then I guess
like after high school I was like you
should model you small eh models so I
just started trying and then it's like
going well you don't really know so you
try I guess really cliche so is your
confidence like really boosted I guess
I'm a pretty confident person all right
in case you guys haven't seen any of our
older videos I'm gonna show you some
pictures of Caroline right now the
amount of times I touched myself to the
photos of Caroline Mitchell or
ridiculous over and over because you're
really skinny and you're big but you
also got big boobs how did you get so
blessed you know
God just really loved you when you were
made as you were being conceived which
I'm sure is an image you want in your
mind right now
totally holy [ __ ] holy crap did that is
incredible that is really sexy I was
there from 4:30 p.m. on Wednesday until
7 a.m.
yes can I make this my background I
could do whatever I want with this photo
can I
i I love this photo a lot LC got here
what else you got here scary-looking
Maleficent looking photo
with Maleficent I think yeah that's true
she changes up her hair a lot yeah yeah
oh wow you can almost see her nipple oh
did you fool around this guy
no she gay he's not gay Wow
Nina gets her none at all do you ever
get turned on working with these models
no hardly
I did get turned on by him and then I
can't talk well my heartbeats racing
right now people I have to do something
to relax myself later and you know what
that is smokes that the combination of
hand on penis pleasure yeah
anyway enough about her we're gonna
watch the trailer for six tape sex tape
I think is what's called I mean there's
a movie called sex tape coming out it's
like a horror film
it's s underscore X tape we should do a
sex tape together we should do a little
one right now don't laugh I've had as a
serious suggestion Oh Laura I wouldn't
taking suggestions here on the Rhine
right show yeah whatever so fine no sex
tape with Caroline yeah yeah we'll watch
the trailer you know what everyone
Caroline you asked for it I'm gonna no
he do it she's got a banana she's got a
banana you know hey but now there's
nothing there this could be you and I
I feel uncomfortable I'm so creeped out
this is he exactly so you don't want to
go to know
made a movie Adam she's like blaming him
for this whole thing wasn't it her idea
to go in there yeah why is she getting
so mad at him like we made a movie Adam
yeah something about it watch it but I
didn't like my watches I know it's
supposed to be like found-footage and
all that [ __ ] but it looks poorly made
it looks incredibly poorly made and the
actress Mac Taurus the actor I don't
know like [ __ ] not her actual look what
is her acting yeah yeah no she's she's
decent looking she's looking and you see
like her crotch in the first few seconds
of the trailer yeah which is always nice
you should do a movie like that one day
I would totally pay to watch it oh my
god I'm looking at you in the eyes
though yeah that movie looks okay it
looks just okay yeah probably I mean you
can make it a found footage movie and
make it look decent that done I think
the idea of the movie is really good
they just had terrible acting and
terrible footage like the idea of a
horror movie going down while trying to
fill a sex tape that's hot someone told
me about the movie I might go yeah yeah
I would like to see that but watching
the footage not pressed they handled
that very poorly would you ever do a sex
tape okay so you would do it like with a
boyfriend or something what does the guy
have to do to become her boyfriend a lot
like what what am i lacking in besides I
know it's not really an accent oh [ __ ] I
can work on that so if okay okay let's
[ __ ] I know I am your height that's not
tall enough is it I know it's not my
looks cuz I'm Way better looking than
you come on look at this you you stand
no word in here a chance
getting with this guy showering yeah
gosh you should feel embarrassed that
you're even next to me right now yeah I
just look better by comparison see this
is so sad
why do you ring me on here to make fun
of me no I just wanted to be next to a
pretty girl furthermore anybody guys
well thank you for recommending that I
did want to watch that trailer but it
does look a little disappointing yeah
I'm not gonna see it I would watch it at
home
yeah I'd watch it at home - I'd like
maybe I might up the scare factor a
little in bed by myself ah would you be
wearing clothes no well it's true that's
true I'm gonna go to the feet are not
wearing clothes that'll be good for
everyone there no you're naked so you
thought a Jaden Smith well if you're new
to the channel
this is button up here hit it subscribe
I want a Carolina come on the channel
more if you like her you gotta tell me
that you like her let me know oh she
will show up more she what are you
living in like 40 minutes away from you
yeah she's pretty far more naked
this is the part of the show Carolina
where I like to give shout outs to fans
of the channel Josh Hopkins he's left a
long comment saying hey guys just want
to let you know you're all [ __ ]
awesome total inspiration you hear that
is Australia good inspiration
probably yeah he's in a band and I've
spent the majority of my day going
through the trailer reactions playlist
always makes me happy to see when you
guys have posted a new video and you all
are truly one of the few really great
YouTube channels mates whenever you get
around to it I love a shout out from you
crazy [ __ ] John next to each
ear but Josh shoutout to you Josh you're
the crazy [ __ ] he said inmate so
I'm gonna assume you're like British or
something man let's just stop but Sally
texting
Sally though [ __ ] this girl has the
best body though that's for sure
all the girls have there's a level the
girls now have to keep up to it and
that's her body is Caroline's and then
everyone else is not gonna watch this
channel anymore
come on after in the insulting oven
right okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna get really cut I'm gonna break my
calves and then I'm gonna grow some
inches develop an Australian accent live
in Australia for four years and then I'm
gonna approach you finally gonna be like
can I take you to cut all tight yeah on
the die that's awful terrible Australian
accent I got ways to go people decayed
what you say yeah so you go two words
for us really accent are Dickie
but Josh no thank you that's really
sweet of you to say all that man you're
really awesome for saying all that you
know it's funny when people see your
inspiration I make it a lot lately
it's concept kind of boosting my ego
Thank You Josh yeah I'm getting a little
cocky
sup baby how you doing ASAP drizzle a
savage rizzo school Jerry's hair is the
goat now give me a shout-out all right
so because you say Jerry's hair is the
goat you must get a shout out is that
what you're telling us man
well a Sabbath what does that mean he
said drizzle I've never heard that
that's just the goat right there I think
of like when a guy has to shake twice
after he pees
that's a go no no no the goat is Jerry's
hair Rimmer Gary is yeah but to go well
he looks like a go now look people say
it looks like Jesus or it go no no
there's there's a reason why you would
burst into flames
a scepter is oh this is your shoutout
too bad Jerry's not here to give you a
Jesus speech but he also said I'm a
boner kill [ __ ] you man what the hell
okay we're taking back your we're taking
back the shoutout man
and we're opposing it with a non boner
killed yeah yeah that's what you have
done mm-hmm
Travis Katie Ryan may have a shot up
also can you please make an
inappropriate sexual joke to Sally in my
honor
okay here we go can you help me out with
this Sally why Sally oh he won't real
pretend we can just say one two squeeze
anyone to sally directly what's a good
sex joke good sex joke come on Caroline
you're all full of sex you I mean here
okay even though my whole career depends
on me being on the phone let's say that
she woke up and then she called me on
the phone okay she was like Carolina
woke up with two black eyes and I was
like what you woke up with two black
eyes and she's like no I got punched and
I woke up with two black eyes what is
that a domestic violent to the black
guys punch her in the eyes that's no
black guys so there was no black guys
it's just she has black eyes okay punch
her she intimidated the hell out of me
in high school I think it sound like we
were friends in high school I just could
not get near well guys that's the
night's episode you tune in next time
whenever I have a video up this is naked
Caroline and